tra tutti grazie a tutti essere qua devo
dire che vedere questo video crea ancora
molta emozione anche a noi ed è bello
vedere che anche parenti e amici che
conosciamo da tanto tempo anche loro
ancora vedono delle cose nuove proprio
che ci fanno capire la particolarità di
questo viaggio che è stata una cosa
trent straordinaria che ancora oggi noi
non riusciamo a rendercene conto di
quanto è stato bello
l'idea come è nata diciamo collegandoci
a questa che è stato l'argomento di oggi
di ponti e passaggi diciamo che dal
punto di vista fisico
in questa avventura ne abbiamo passati
tanti però la cosa che più ci ha colpito
come si può vedere anche dalle foto che
ora continuano a scorrere che nonostante
il viaggio che ci ha portato proprio da
una parte all'altra del mondo con una
panda che credo tutti qui in italia
sappiamo di che mezzo si tratta è stato
anche quello di un passaggio diverso dal
solito un passaggio di cultura che non è
il classico che sia si effetto in un
viaggio facciamo di routine vedere un
passaggio di cultura veramente diverso
titolo perché mi hanno detto alcune cose
da dire ma come sicuramente quelle che
avevo detto di non dire io le ho dette e
sarà il contrario hanno insistito che
parlavo di questa diciamo che questo
passaggio che ne abbiamo fatto è stato
anche soprattutto della nostra comfort
zone che abbiamo oramai non solo in
italia ma in tutta quella che l'europa è
un po in tutto il mondo diciamo che in
questo viaggio non è questa con forza
non abbiamo un po superata perché avevo
visto degli ambienti e delle cose che
effettivamente in un primo momento ci
hanno spaventato anche se non ci hanno
messo in pericolo è stato difficile
organizzarlo coinvolgere amici parenti
sponsor per organizzare tutta questa
cosa nata da un'idea semplice in una
sera d estate parlando sui viaggi fatti
su quelli che si vogliono fare poi
diciamo è seguito quello che stata
l'organizzazione vera e propria finché
poi abbiamo realizzato di partire
veramente solo pochi giorni prima della
partenza quando avevamo tutto pronto
veramente non eravamo capaci di quello
che stiamo facendo
infatti passa la parola al mio compagno
emiliano che entra nel dettaglio della
partenza di questo viaggio si buonasera
a tutti emiliano
allora come diceva prima pietro che va
tolto tutto quanto il discorso che devo
fare
il nostro viaggio comunque adesso è da
qualche parte devo andare a parare il
nostro viaggio è stato un viaggio che
comunque ha conosciuto un sacco di ponti
e passaggi ecco perché diciamo si sposa
bene con il tema della serata
tra cui quello di più bello che abbiamo
attraversato più famose stato quello del
bosforo un ponte di collegamento fra
incidente oriente un pochettino il
viaggio abbiamo fatto noi però il
diciamo vorrei fare un il ponte più
bello che mi piacerebbe raccontare e un
ponte non tanto fisico ma quanto
virtuale quanto metafisico ovvero quel
ponte che ha collegato noi la basilicata
con la mongolia in quanto come proprio
il ponte fondamentalmente un'opera
ingegneristica architettonica che serve
per collegare due sponde to party down
da una sponda conosciuta perché sai
benissimo il panorama rosciano e via
discorrendo
vai verso un altra sponda un'altra
sponda che comunque sia potresti anche
non conoscerla è la stessa cosa è
successo a noi durante questo viaggio
mano a mano mano a mano che facevamo km
lasciavamo un pezzettino di quella che
era la nostra storia nostra cultura le
nostre conoscenze quindi il singolo
albero il singolo al singolo ciottolo
del panorama né conosciuto su quella
sponda per arrivare verso un altra
sponda che non conoscevamo verso
l'ignoto però un ponte non si può
erigere diciamo senza un altra sponda
quindi dall'altro lato c'era un qualcosa
e quel qualcosa era fatta di culture
diverse di tradizioni diverse di
sorprese ogni volta diverse e che
abbiamo cercato di sintetizzare qua
dentro non ci siamo riusciti perché
comunque stato un viaggio ritrovato 27
giorni però la cosa diciamo che può
riassumere tutta quanta l'esperienza e
il fatto se dito prima parlare un sacco
di tecnologia eccetera eccetera
la cosa bella quando si affrontano
questi viaggi e che fondamentalmente
ho detto un albergo perdonami
e come se tornassi verso un punto zero
non c'è la tecnologia non ci sono tante
cose che al giorno d'oggi e magari per
noi sarebbero difficile riuscire a
vivere senza
eppure mano a mano invece ti cominci ad
abituarti c cominci magari è riuscire a
dialogare con una personale di fronte
non tramite di inglese una lingua
convenzionale ma solamente tramite il
simbolo dei gesti perché io non parlo la
lingua sua ma lui non parla la lingua mi
ha però in qualche modo che mi stavo
rare un discorso e poi il il sunto
generale quello che realmente mi ha
lasciato questa esperienza è stata la
generosità delle persone che abbiamo
conosciuto ogni persona ci ha sempre
dato un qualcosina per poter proseguire
il nostro viaggio è arrivare a quella
che era meta che è stata poi la mongolia
devo dire che l'intervento ha fatto la
sua parte quindi è un po un po più
semplice professore ha detto netta del
tuo grazie portatutto l'attraversamento
di questi conti sia fisici sia a pochi
che si costruiscono e si attraversano
dal punto di vista personale portano all
inevitabile cambiamento
ma l'aspetto più bello del cambiamento e
che man mano che si cambia si avverte la
resistenza al cambiamento va scemando
quindi cosa accade che all'inizio c'è un
impatto verso il nuovo ed è di un
impatto forte e un impatto a volte anche
difficile da gestire perché ci sono
tante difficoltà che qui in italia
sembra uno sembrerebbero delle
difficoltà minime ma in un posto dove
non si parla la stessa lingua dove a
volte anche gesti sono diversi una
minima difficoltà diventa un enorme
difficoltà e all'inizio questo impatto è
stato molto forte
il bello è stato che più passava il
tempo più scorrevano i chilometri più
questo impatto andata diminuendo più
questo importo diventava parte della
nostra quotidianità
e questo ci faceva capire man mano che
il cambiamento stava facendo parte di
nubi e questo cambiamento non è finito
con l'arrivo mongolia
ma è un cambiamento che continua a far
parte della nostra quotidianità della
nostra vita è associato diversamente
anche quella che sono le cose più
semplici che prima vivevano in maniera
di routine da ci accorgiamo che
effettivamente non ovunque così e non
per tutti è così
in questo cambiamento cosa ci ha
lasciato ci ha lasciato una cosa che
forse la cosa più bella che è quella di
non rendere questa avventura una
parentesi ma è quella di volerla
continuare
e infatti oggi serie the city primi a
sapere della della prossima avventura
che sarà la costruzione di un nuovo
ponte sia fisico e sia anche metafisico
personale intrapreso da noi questa volta
non verso oriente ma verso occidente
e da nord a sud e quindi faremo una cosa
che sarà nuova per tutti che
l'attraversamento da new york fino a rio
de janeiro sempre con la palla
lo sapevo neanche io
pensiamo per per tutto è per noi è un
piacere poter esporre quella che è stata
la nostra avventura e spero che ci
continuate a seguire a sostenerci per la
prossima
grazie stava ancora aprono le porte
aspetto è vero che non è tutto
noi abbiamo finito per la quinta questa
la dieta già scattata c'è ancora qualche
foto abbiamo cacciamo la vedere
facciamola vedere no dicevo sono qui
sono stati bravi in realtà perché come
dicevo ieri ci hanno raccontato tre
viaggi diversi simpatici sono state
anche molto diplomatici ricordavo in
questo ponte tra i linguaggi le
soluzioni cioè come chiedere un nuovo a
qualcuno emiliano vuoi farci vedere come
mi hai chiesto di nuovo bene le figure
sono moto va bene ringraziamo
assolutamente emiliano francesco e
pietro facciamo scorrere le figure
commentiamo le se volete piuttosto
questa commentato è finito il tennis mi
segnala la mia caporeparto che è finito
il tempo a vostra disposizione